دفعت الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وتهديدات
الصينيه لتايوان وتجارب كوريا الشماليه
اليابان والمانيا الى التخلص من قيود
الحرب العالميه الثانيه واعاده ضبط
سياستهم العسكريه وفق المتغيرات الجديده
اليابان التي تواجه في محيطها الاسيوي
تحديات بيجن وبيوميان اعلنت هذا الشهر
عقيده عسكريه جديده تنص على مضاعفه
ميزانيه الدفاع خلال السنوات الخمس
المقبله والتزوج بصواريخ بعيده المدى
كما انضمت اليابان قبل عامين الى ما يعرف
بحلس خوات العسكري الذي يضم الهند
واستراليا والولايات المتحده لمواجهه
منفوض الصين المتزايد
ضمن التوجه الجديد ايضا دخلت اليابان في
شراكه مع بريطانيا وايطاليا لتطوير مقاتله
النفاثه تستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي وهي
المره الاولى التي تتعاون فيها طوكيو مع
دول اخرى غير الولايات المتحده في مشروع
للمعدات العسكريه اما المانيا التي ترتبط
مخاوفها اساسا بروسيا بعد حربها على
اوكرانيا فقد اسست صندوقا خاصا بقيمه 100
مليار يورو لتحديث الجيش ورفع حجم الانفاق
العسكري بدءا من العام المقبل
اتخذت برلين خطوات عسكريه غير مسبوقه منذ
انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه في امداد
اوكرانيا بالصواريخ والعتاد
وكذلك ابرمت صفقه مع واشنطن لشراء مقاتلات
متطوره من طراز 35
هذه التحولات كلها تتقاطع في اليابان
والمانيا مع توجهات الولايات المتحده
حلفتهم الاقوى والاقدم التي تعتبر وجود
خلفاء اقوى يخفف عنها العبء ويعزز رضع
الخصوم